but first up oh wow he wrote the book
that President Trump didn't want you to
buy so you did walk through fire and
carry inside the trap White House
Michael whoa
[Applause]
well you have done the impossible you
have made America read again you know if
it's if it's a book that brings down
this presidency I'm going to bow to the
god of irony well it with all due
respect it's a great fun book to read
but it's not bringing him down his
popularity has not gone down one bit his
base wouldn't read it the people who
read it already hate him but it's fun
and it's informative you just can't move
these people that's the thing but and I
know you've been out talking about it I
want you to tell me something that the
other people have not noticed in this
book is there something that you think
boy why don't they ask me about this
that I put in there that they're not
talking about there is but I can't tell
you what it is so there is teasing this
like that there is something in the in
the book that I'd write I was absolutely
sure of but it was so incendiary that
that I just didn't have the the the
ultimate foolproof entering what he's
done what is it a woman thing well I
yeah I didn't have the blue dress there
was it about a woman it is oh it is it
is
oh it's somebody's [ __ ] now it is oh
and it's whose you just have to read
between the lines what lines tell us the
line you say it's in the book it's
toward the end of the bouquet well it's
in the book and we go you know you just
you just have to you'll know it oh now
that I've told you what ku when you hit
that paragraph you're gonna write ingo
okay I'm not gonna make the joke I was
gonna be okay so listen the womanizing
thing though you do have a lot about it
in the book I mean that I found
fascinating that you were basically
saying that this is sort of the point of
trumps whole life I love the way you say
you know the Empire the bit really was a
boutique industry kind of he really
didn't do anything all day the whole
point of his existence was chasing tail
24/7 24/7 that was it
that is the he's in the man I am an
old-fashioned Playboy that's the kind of
thing that he says and he says it
proudly yeah and I always thought I may
have said it last year that your I
thought one of the biggest adjustments
for him was when he moves into the White
House he can't play the key you know
when it was Maloney Oh be home at 8:00
and then he guys hotels you know he goes
to dog tournaments we see as all these
places where he can get together with
his mistresses that's hard to do in the
White House that's probably why he's so
pissed off all the time I come except
now he's got yeah I mean there's got
their back door
there are back doors and back doors
there are back doors oh it's a gay
liaison you know listen I didn't think
of that
[Applause]
Sean Spicer if I can get into the White
House you know get into the white and
this is the other thing that's so
fascinating about your book besides
what's in the book just the fact that
you were able to hang out hang out like
it's a dorm room like you know just this
is the White House that just blew my
mind that people weren't saying who's
this guy why is he here every day what's
he's listening to us every day I waited
for someone to notice me say please get
out but they don't they actually do the
other thing they sort of say okay come
come let's let's talk and what do you
attribute this to I tribute to Donald
Trump this is like he said okay he liked
you because you were in New Yorker well
sort of Nereus he gave the first
approval I said I'd like to come you
know come down and and observe right
then he thought I was asking for a job I
said no no I said I want to write a book
and he said you just saw he was deflated
the book why would you want to do that
but then it was kind of like okay what
was the tight right you had it you
didn't call it fire and fury when you
were talking to them right it was like
the grand transitioners yes the great
transition a greater of course that's
funny you know when Larry Charles and I
were making my documentary Religulous we
didn't call it that we called it a
spiritual journey and then they let us
interview them in the church it's now I
told Trump he said you know I said I'm
gonna call the book the great transition
the first hundred days right he said a
boring title right so the other thing
that where you actually had an impact is
because of the book there was a lot of
talk about maybe he's just flat-out
batshit nuts people were diagnosed I
mean they was talking about that before
but it reached a fever pitch to the
point where he thought that we had his
physical last week that he also asked to
take a cognitive test and then bragged
about how great he did even though it
was a test that it's the kind of test to
give an old lady when she's wandering
the middle of the highway in her
underpants it's it's also you can get
the test on the internet so you can get
the questions before him it's it's 30
questions the first four are what month
is it what day is it what year is it
what city are you in and who's the
president thing you know yeah okay so
you know it goes that your book goes up
to what where John Kelly takes over okay
so that is the big watershed moment but
this week now he's apparently feuding as
I referred to in the Mon elected with
John Kelly because Kelly committed the
ultimate faux pas and he criticized
Trump on TV or inferred that he was not
perfect what do you make of this and
apparently I read now that John Kelly
threatens to quit all the time that's
the only way you can get Trump's
attention everybody tries to quit the
whole operation is that true yeah that's
it's like how do I get out of here
so why does he still command so much
loyalty
he's been so rotten and said rotten
things to just about everybody and all I
see is month after month Republicans not
fighting him more lining up behind him
more lying for him what do you attribute
that to
well I mean I think the loyalty thing my
book is sort of the example that that
these are the most disloyal loyal people
who have ever existed but but also the
Republicans you know there was you know
Mitch McConnell said this was early on
he will sign anything we put in front of
him so he just becomes for everyone in
some way a useful fool now the problem
with that is he's the useful fool but
then he goes wacko and says something
which destroys everybody's plans to use
him so what do you and what are you
involve with him I'm not saying admire I
did nothing I admire about him but there
are things about him that I am in awe of
I think the size of his balls aren't you
just in awe of the size of it you know
come on I mean I am in awe that that
there is actually someone who can go
through life reach the age of what is it
71 right now and still act like he
should get what he wants when he wants
without anyone saying otherwise demand
demand demand
because everything is so unfair his
favorite word is unfair
he's the luckiest guy in the world and
he's got this chip on his shoulder
that's that's what I understand the
moral attitude is when will white men
born to great wealth finally catch a
break in America
[Applause]
[Music]
or his as everyone I mean literally a
hundred percent of the people around him
always return to saying well he's like a
child right and sometimes he's a sixteen
year is like a sixteen year old child or
an 11 year old Laura to you I noticed
now on Fox and Friends they talked to
him directly like they used to on romper
room
I see Donald it's the funnest book I've
read in a long time I just hope the
world stays where it is thank you so
much
[Music]
[Applause]